we feel incredibly humbled by this award  and would like to express our deepest  gratitude to the academy for recognizing  our work  it certainly would not have been  possible without the great leadership at  weather digital  particularly we want to thank john le  terry for his trust and enthusiasm to  raise the bar whenever possible  our thanks go to the amazing creature  department for their support and  feedback in particular andrea mello  john homer carlos lin kevin kelm matthew  mateen and josh johnston  also the sign ups team who helped build  and support the foundations for this  project  tim ebling john farrow michael ferro  sean mario bri john at home andrea  sotostrom and chris edwards  you guys are amazing most importantly we  want to thank our families  wives and children for the patience and  support during these years which was not  always easy  but without them none of this would have  happened so thank you very very much